welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the Loki series on Disney Plus
has its first official look since that
brief trailer shot showing Loki in the
time variant authority jumpsuit that I
found a million things to say about how
spoiler warning before I continue in
case you click on predictive YouTube
videos for details you don't want to
know because you hate yourself and
before we begin this video is brought to
you by Squarespace from websites and
online stores to marketing tools an
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and we run your business and
newly released images Tom Hiddleston as
Loki joins co-star Owen Wilson Wow
apparently it's some crime-scene
procedural scenario across the spectrum
of Marvel timelines some crimes are
considered of the time variety these
crimes are investigated by a specific
authority of time investigators this is
Loki time cops
[Music]
[Music]
and among these images are a couple
other Marvel Easter eggs that could
confirm the confusing timeline logic of
the series Wow there's a lady Loki now
there's multiverses knots
I can't believe I escaped the West
Anderson Cinematic Universe for this
okay the first thing to point out here
is Owen Wilson he's wearing a jacket
stamped with that TV a logo so just as
we expected he seems to be playing an
agent of the time variants Authority
they're flanked by cops in Swat gear a
similar type helmets as the TV a patrol
officers in the comics Wilson's
different appearance from them suggests
that he could be a higher ranking
detective maybe a chrono monitor or
maybe one of the judges like justice
peace but loki is also geared up
similarly so perhaps after getting
detained by the TVA as the one at a
place piece of evidence from the
avengers timeline Medlen and endgame
Lukie is being given the option to work
off his debt to time society by helping
the TVA solve some time crimes these six
episodes of this season could be a kind
of police procedural as the TVA goes
timeline by timeline trying to track
down some elusive time-traveling menace
like kang the conqueror as i've
speculated before or if we really want
to get crazy recent fox acquisitions
like Doctor Doom or cable but the
biggest reveal of these set photos is
actress Sophia DiMartino suited up in an
interesting low-key style costume now
there's a bit of a debate over whether
she's playing the Marvel character
interests or the character I suspect
she's playing lady Loki unlike other
female Marvel characters with female
titles attached to the male name you
know is she-hulk
Miss Marvel Spider Woman girl Avenger
but Lady Luck is a whole different thing
lady Loki is actually Loki's a spirit in
a female form same character new body
this came about in the 2008 Thor comics
when Thor after the Ragnarok events
comes to earth to build a new Asgard in
Broxton Oklahoma and he seeks out the
scattered as Guardians whose essences
are now inhabiting the bodies of humans
around the world eventually Thor comes
across who he thinks is Jane Foster in
the body of Lady SIF but it's actually
Loki in that body
Loki lives on as a woman for the next
few years in the comics throughout the
Dark Reign event she joins forces with
Doctor Doom
so if DiMartino is playing lady
okey what is she doing in the same
spaces Tom Hiddleston boy Loki is Loki
transforming into a female version of
himself like how he swapped in a cap an
end game and in Thor the dark world well
I doubt it DiMartino appears to be
credited for all six episodes and you
know switching genders back and forth
like that that's kind of a joke
am i tending the wrong kind of message
remember this is also a show about time
cops investigating alternate timelines
alternate realities so different
versions of Schrodinger's Loki can exist
in the same place at the same time
specifically if this Loki series is
following the rules of Lady Loki in the
comics her presence here my actually
pinpoint exactly where this is taking
place across the ever-expanding MCU
multiverse now yes it is fun to hunt for
these details but sometimes I just wish
two people were released this stuff will
just display it all in one pretty easy
to navigate website if only they use
Squarespace and thanks to Squarespace
for sponsoring this video
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business are you looking for a
website to sell your fan art nobody else
is doing MCU characters in the style of
old-timey photo booth and the world
deserves to see it present your work
using squarespace's professional
portfolio designs display projects and
customizable galleries and add
password-protected pages to share
private work with clients you can auto
post your content to Twitter Facebook or
tumblr you can also easily import from
Instagram Twitter and other platforms to
give your site deep personal visual
player that you want to Squarespace will
even sell you a URL now I'm not sure if
I am and gentlemen comm is still
available but you know you should check
quick head to Squarespace comm for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to our custom URL in the
description to save 10% off your first
purchase of website or domain so again
lady loki comes about as a consequence
of the Ragnarok event Ragnarok causes
these spirits of Asgardians to scatter
and inhabit new identities the
Asgardians of the EM sewer also in a
post Ragnarok stage of the cycle in
Norse mythology and the Thorkelson
inspired Ragnarok is a cyclical event of
destruction and rebirth including the
destruction of Asgard but since Asgard
is not a place it's a people also the
symbolic transformation of the Asgardian
people in the MCU Loki died immediately
following Ragnarok now he died at the
enters his hand to begin an infinity war
but it immediately succeeded the
destruction of Asgard and he died at the
price of the
stolen tesseract from Odin's vault on
Asgard and his death was marked with all
kinds of deep Norse symbolism
I assure you brother the Sun will shine
on us again so what if as part of the
Ragnarok cycle of transformation the
moment Loki died Loki's ashes moved on
and now possesses the body of Sophia
DiMaggio earth now the key thing here is
that this would be in the prime MCU
reality earth nine nine nine nine nine
because Loki died an infinity war
connecting all of this to the post
in-game timeline the ax Tom it'll spin
Loki that we follow in that's Disney
Plus series is the Loki that escaped
from the 2012 time heist attempt causing
a new branch timeline where he then
intercepted by the TVA and put to work
now it looks like one stop in their
investigation could be going back to the
prime MCU timeline where Loki is now
lady looking another detail that points
in this direction is the bus in these
set photos
it says rocks cart evacuation shuttle
now that Roxx prefix suggests a
connection with the Roxxon corporation
the oil industrial conglomerate formerly
the weapon manufacturer run by Justin
Hammer in Iron Man movies now it appears
that rocks on could be taken over
evacuation efforts from disaster zones
maybe as a kind of private sector FEMA
turn in the various disasters of the MCU
into profit formerly Stark Industries
was involved in this kind of work
providing funding for the department of
damage control after Loki's Chitauri
invasion which ended up putting
blue-collar workers like Adrian Toomes
out of work perhaps now the Tony Stark
is dead in the main MCU timeline rival
corporations like Roxxon are swooping in
to exploit and monetize the hell out of
every disaster smashing capitalism in
this case judging by that heavy rainfall
I'm thinking the disaster is a hurricane
or tornado maybe some kind of stormy
weather stirred up by a certain mutant -
now as surfaced in this MCU phase I
cannot wait for MCU storms over dramatic
monologue
Wow
and here deputy Timecop Loki will find
himself joining TV a court monitor or
justice on Wilson Wow with a female
destination body of Loki's post Ragnarok
essence in the prime post in game Marvel
earth 199 yeah this shows not gonna be
confusing at all or more of our Marvel
theories and speculation be sure to join
our official discord server where we
chew on all is stuff with our inner
circle of supporters access our discord
by becoming a patron of new rock stars
today at patreon.com slash new rock
stars Tom and Emily with your low key
theories follow me Eddie a vos follow
new rock stars and subscribed into
wrestlers here on YouTube for breakdowns
of everything Marvel thanks for watching
bye these crimes are love
[Music]